welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
live today's episode is sponsored by
hims naturebox
Dollar Shave Club kaptara and the Elder
Scrolls legends next week oh my god I
forgot to put the thread up again every
time we'll be up after the live and
before the vaad hits youtube but next
week we have Tommy Wiseau the creator
and star of the room finger he's coming
on I'd say we'd had a tweet exchange
with him we spoke with his manager this
morning and it's confirmed it's also are
the last episode of this season one but
I'll talk more about that later there's
a thread up for questions for Tommy on
our subreddit go ahead and post them
there but let's get on to this week's
guest the illustrious and wonderful
Brendon green creator producer designer
of the massively successful most played
game on Steam yes biggest game ever on
Steam yes well not officially out today
yes we yeah with an astonishing 25
million copies sold approximately right
oh yeah 25 uh-huh and concurrent players
in the millions I've never seen anything
they just smashed we're going three
million concurrence today if you think
about that that's one-third or one out
of every hundred Americans playing this
game at once but it's I wonder what's
the geographical breakdown of that I
have a data team that worried about yeah
yeah sure but it had any rate oh no it's
been it's not it's like globally growing
and it's crazy I've know I've honestly
not seen anything like it since
minecraft really this game has pretty
much defined this year in gaming it's
unprecedented and I'm very happy and
honored to introduce Brendon green thank
you for joining us I appreciate it nice
wonderful salve year before we get into
deep here I just want to say if you guys
have any questions please give us a call
at eight one eight two one four eight
five zero four that's not your personal
number right okay
he was saying he thought he'd be funny
if we just posted his person over give
him a call do you have any question I'd
be a little twisted on the joke so for
people that don't know you or the game
can you talk a little bit about what pub
G is and what is the Battle Royale genre
okay so I started making mods like four
or five years ago on ARMA 2 and then
moved ARMA 3 and I created this
game-mode the battle royale game-mode
right and it got licensed by h1 about
three years ago now for inclusion in h1
that eventually became king of the kill
and then last year Blue Hole contacted
me from Korea and said we love what
you've done with a battle royale game
we'd like you to lead a team and make
your own battle royale and pop G was
born out of that so how did you get
that's like a lot and oh yeah right you
know there's like first of all how did
you get into making them a mod for ArmA
like so yeah where were you at the time
give me your humble story your humble
beginnings okay so I started off in
Brazil I would therefore love and
looking divorce and then was saving to
come home and I got back into gaming by
finding the dayz mod' I'd read some
stuff on Reddit Abed and I thought this
sounds really cool there's no rules
there's nothing it's just survive and I
really liked that idea with just a
survival game all right so I kind of
fell in love with the dayz mod and
formed or found a squad to play with
them that's how I kind of learned about
modding cuz the dayz mod was a mod so I
had a look at how it was made are you
were you programming then no I was a web
designer photographer I knew code just
from using javascript and jQuery so if I
died in websites but you know I wasn't a
coder my code is terrible like if people
tell me to fix the game if I try to fix
the game the servers would explode you
know your computer would burn so you
were able to make it using the modding
tools well yes so the code in an ARMA
sqf is kind of like JavaScript so it's
kind of an easy to understand so I just
looked at what other people had done and
beg borrow and stole code and just like
fast people just like for help and
the community and arm have really really
helpful about like helping you so I
created my own dayz mod' server for
people to play on messed with loot
tables just created more weapons and we
ended up creating something people
called like the cod of of dayz because
it was just about the PvP it was there
was no real survival it was just you
died didn't give a [ __ ] go one and just
keep going again right and again and
again and just it's all about the PvP so
after doing that for about six months I
kind of decided listen I wanted to make
a mod I'd seen what Brian Hicks and
Jordan ter did with the survivor games
this kind of streamer centric
competition and I liked what they did
but I thought okay I want to play this
I'm a streamer and I can't so let me see
if I can make something and I thought I
could improve some things they were
doing and battle royale game-mode was
born on Daisy
I basically modded a mod that's so great
it's it's incredible
and it's inspiring that you without even
being much of a background in pro or
game - oh yeah I know I disabled a very
many games I mean I wasn't like big
gamer you know oh I don't like this
seeing some of the people I meet at
conventions I am in no way a gamer I
just don't know how I wonder if that's
why I actually really loved the game
player I know like I'm not a gamer at
all
from the first moment I saw Ethan play
it I was like that's why like you you
were not a gamer necessarily and you
made again that you wanted to play
exactly yeah that's what I think it's
like I wasn't sort of I didn't have
rules of game design to follow I didn't
like when I first went to blue hole I
had many arguments with JC or League
game designer because he was like but
that's not the way I was taught to make
games or the way that they were taught
to make games I was like but it's okay
to break the rules here because people
obviously enjoy it and when I came to
making it it was it was very especially
the first one if you complained it was
too hard I'd make it harder you know it
was like you know I didn't like easy
games I liked to be challenged and I
like I think you know the win rating in
our game the amount of times you win is
so much lower than every other game you
know but that's the joy of it you know
it is because it's tough it's easy
concept survive right um it's a tough
game to master so I think that's why
it's been so frustrating right
oh yeah oh my god I've plucked many
hours and I my background is like I
played like 2,000 hours of dota 2 mmm
and I've played like a thousand hours
plus of counter-strike hmm and so I have
experienced an FPS and I get [ __ ] but
it's addictive you can't stop cuz you
start with nothing right it's every yeah
you know it's funny we had doctor
disrespect on here and he described it
the best way I've heard anyone say I'm
like why is this game so popular and he
says to me it's the story right every
new game has a story there's a narrative
experience its compresses that kind of
Daisy like long story into like 30
minutes and it's like what did I get
this round oh I got the S case yeah
anxious and and I just I think it
compresses that just unique story every
time and it's a simple game to learn you
know it's gotta be the popular he's got
to be tied in to the fact that it's such
watchable hmm it's a it's by far the
most streamed game oh yeah and it's
really fun to watch which is uh like if
you compared to something like dota 2
ice even though I love the game I can't
watch it I can't like I don't I've been
to League tournaments in uh in Korea I
don't understand these games yeah I know
it's like unless you pay especially
don't it like you have you see they have
the noob stream you know where the
commentator is kind of going well this
is why this is like this you have to
have played like a thousand hours just
to understand what you're watching yeah
but and and our game is simple to watch
you know it's it's very easy to
understand and even like you know this
guy is toast he's a hearthstone player
he said even like when he's playing
hearts on his mother and sister have no
clue you know of no interest but when
he's 9 babji they're like oh this is the
settler right ya know and that's I think
again it's the simplicity of the game
it's like and it's just the randomness
every time you know it's still not super
random but it is that it's a unique
story of reader so when you saw when you
started working on her you had the idea
to make this was it like you saw it as a
as a business opportunity that was there
or were you was it just a passion real
like hey this is a great thing I want to
develop this I wanted to make a game I
wanted to play like I wanted to play the
survivor games I thought this is a
really cool game mode right but because
it was for streamers only I couldn't
play it and I thought okay I want to
just try this and then see if I can make
a game mode that I can play with my
friends and if other people enjoy
even you know if not I still have a game
mode I can play with my friends right
there was my intention just have a a
popular server you know that would you
know people would enjoy playing the game
like when we had a popular dayz mod'
server I would sit on the server like
four hours at night just kicking people
with low bandwidth not playing the game
just like hiding in a bush and kicking
people with low bandwidth so everyone
else on the server could enjoy because
I'm low bandwidth if you had low
bandwidth you desync the whole server
really right that's it's just a way that
the armour network code of the time
worked huh that if you have a bad
connection you'd like it because it
wasn't like it was just synchronous
packets or like a single spot if one
person got blocked then all these other
ones got blocked and then people will
get kicked because they're getting no
response so you are just ensuring that
the server experience yes wrong to keep
a good and I didn't mind if you were
like but don't you want to play less
like well no these people can play when
I say you know and I like like seeing a
night without any yellow or red chains
you know you're kind of gone yeah that's
[ __ ] awesome so I made this for those
people to enjoy it wasn't I always saw
it as kind of I'd love to do a big
spectacle in eSports you know because
I'd see like dota and csgo and stuff and
yes these events are massive but it's
still two teams of five on the stage you
know and I wanted to fill a stadium with
people and put like a hundred people in
the centre and you know and that kind of
big like spectacle in eSports rather
than just two teams of five is that
where you see the game going I hope so
like I mean really I mean that's that's
the dream for me is like one point
always great and we get to raise a full
game but until we have our first major
that's where I really see kind of rife
it's kind of that's the dream completes
them you want our stadium with a hundred
players at the in the pit or the field
yeah and have like whatever thirty forty
thousand people watching I'm having that
first person to get down walk off yeah
shame it's like a long walk oh yeah
people in the audience like heads of
lettuce throw down that would actually
be quite I can see when it comes down to
like the final two or three of that that
would be pretty exhilarating right
[Music]
that's fine oh yeah but this like I mean
that's what I always dreamed that that
could be a great eSport you know and I
think it's I still think it could be so
what do you think are the
challenges that exist that you might
that you're aware of or want to overcome
to make sure that pub G can become a
great sport we have to get the game
eSports ready right I mean it's not
competitive well it is competitive but
it's not it's not completely bug free
you know there's lots of stuff we have
to improve and that's what we want to
spend like you know I keep saying like
this is 1.0 is a milestone for us it's
not the end of development we want to
continue over the next year to keep
improving you know that there may be
problems that launch tonight but we're
not gonna just leave them you know we
want to keep fixing and some of these
problems are really really hard to fix
you know there's there's problems that
are with the core engine itself that if
we try to fix them or touch them it
might end up with a hundred other
problems you know you're talking about
issues like pure rubber banding but this
is the big lie so rubber banding is
frustrating for me alone yeah so the why
that is and we're still trying to figure
it out but it's basically there we are
graded the engine from four one six or
four one four four one six right and
that change gave us a lot of network
problems and we're still trying to
figure out why those are occurring but
its core engine code and it's we have a
small team still relatively speaking
what we're still expanding but it's it's
quite tough to find good talent right
you know and tantor fits the company and
talent understands you know what we're
doing and are good enough to you know to
do the job we need them to do so it's
time you can't throw money at it you
know it's it just takes time and
eventually we get them but it's it just
yeah it's the network problem it's still
gonna be there probably at launch you
may see some rubber banding which sucks
but it's we're still trying to fix it
you know and it's I'm sure frustrates
you guys as much as people that are
always complaining oh no I mean it's
like you know oh no like we have like
guys that are in the office you know 14
15 hour days trying to figure this [ __ ]
out like really like they pour their
hearts and soul into it like if there's
a problem with the service today they
will not leave the office until the
servers are fix you know that they're
really dedicated to making this a great
experience and it when I hear people
like ragging on the dev team really like
I get mad because it's like you don't
understand how hard they work they
really you know and some people like oh
but we pay you know this you we expect
them to work 24 hours a day you know
the issue is that the game has become
almost unreasonably successful it's a
pre-release oh well at least until
tonight is the official release right
that's right and so you've got melee
you've sold 25 million copies but and
then people forget you know that this is
a pre-release and people are expecting
because you guys have so much revenue
coming in oh there's no excuse right I
know but I mean even our servers and
like you know functions like battle
lines about it costs in millions of
dollars you know it for what a month you
know per month for servers for all these
additional costs that like yes we have
made some money from selling the game
but there's all these additional costs
that you don't realize you know under
we've tried throwing monies at servers
but that doesn't fix them you know it's
like it takes time and a lot of these as
I said are really their core engine
issues that you have to do them very
carefully because like that's why we
couldn't update the live servers with
the test build was because there were so
many issues with the test build because
it was a different version of the engine
that we couldn't roll it out to three
million people you know or 25 million
people you know we just couldn't do that
to the play race that's why we had to
keep the live version was stable it
wasn't great but it was stable whereas
the test version not so stable but now
we've got to a stage now that there may
still be crashes there may be so be real
rounding but we are still working on it
you know yeah we want to you know we
want to get it stable we want to get a
kind of here yeah so gameplay-wise
work what do you see are the challenges
has become to becoming a competitive
game
we just need to balance stuff like the
blue zone you know we really do need to
do some passes on the blue zone to make
it more competitive and fairer for
players so people who don't know what
the blue zone is in the game this battle
royale genre I guess you would call it
there's a never shrinking plays
aggressive there's ever shrinking play
zone the timer runs out and there's this
blue cancer the creeps towards you and
if you don't stand beside the blue wall
you die yeah and so what about that is
is unbalanced in your opinion we just
have to look at like you know sometimes
it may jump too much or that the
distance may be too long or it might be
moving too fast so we haven't had a lot
of times always moving too fast right
but no I mean it's it's these kind of
things that we need to look at the data
and the players and and figure out like
what is best competitively for the game
to give everyone a fair chance and that
takes time but you know look at csgo
they're still releasing small updates
everything was right and that's we want
to be that you know that's what we want
that we want to continue to use over the
next 10 20 years you know and it we're
gonna take time to balance this but know
we have the data we just need to pick
through it so it just takes time these
you know this is I keep saying this is
just not a marathon or this is not a
sprint for us this is really a marathon
like it's we were building a team now
that we want to support this for 10 20
years you know and yeah one thing that
for me has been the hallmark of every
game with longevity has been and I guess
you would appreciate this more anyone
this scene for modding and custom games
okay I look back did you ever play like
Starcraft or Warcraft trying to conquer
yeah that did they have modding I don't
remember no I don't think so
but at least I didn't mod so at any rate
starcraft brood war I played that game
for like a decade and most we would
played that didn't even play the actual
competitive aspect one was playing the
custom maps is that something you guys
have planned well if we'd love to like
we have custom games already right you
guys know yeah clay that a lot of them
which is great right and we want to give
more fine great control over those
custom games so you can really start
playing around and creating unique link
other game modes like now that right I
just give you guys so much control and
and maybe allow you know other things to
plug into that but you know as for
complete modding like you'd see say an
armor maybe not yes you know I don't
know because this is a competitive game
so like what I want like this is going
to be a competitive game so if you start
opening up to modding it opens up to
cheating and a whole thing really it
opens up to cheating well it's it just
means that like you're opening up parts
of your engine to let people play with
and I don't think that if we don't do it
correctly it could end up you know being
bad for security so you know we realize
there's this whole like you know that we
can't just add modding you know because
we need to and as well like you know
releasing our server files for people to
host our own servers again will you know
could lead to priority and in China and
so forth at where someone releases an
exact clone of our game and you know
things like this so like these are all
kind of things that we really have to
consider carefully like cuz some games
is like modding like um I really want to
bring that like you know into the fore
and kind of make it that people who have
no idea how to mod a game can do it via
a UI panel you know and kind of do it
that way so we can lock the security
down but still give people you know
custom games interesting
I was wondering cuz I never got the
opportunity to sit down with someone and
as a competitive gamer myself
hackers are the [ __ ] bane of of
gaming experience you're not csgo
Starcraft 2 hackers ruin every
experience what's your philosophy with
dealing with hackers and is it that hard
for a publisher to snub it out oh yeah
are there companies that did they hide
their cleaning up of hacking as an
excuse to sell more copies of the game I
can I mean yeah I don't know I mean I
can just talk from my experience that
like it's an ongoing battle likes these
the hack the guys who write these cheats
are smart you know well I happen to know
some of them from years ago in arm and
stuff and the way they think about code
the way they think about operating
systems is just so unique that like oh
go can I get into this from this and a
lot of them aren't even hacking the game
they're hacking other programs on
Windows and then going in via unsecure
dll's into memory and then accessing
your game view memory and it's it's like
it's like basing malware level cheats
are coming out of like China that like
these things are like so difficult to
track and like we have a great
anti-cheating battle I like when it
comes to memory and client based or
their honestly one of the best but now
we have statistics anti-cheat coming in
and other stuff like we're putting layer
upon layer to really try secure the game
but it just takes time you know
especially if it's just this the system
the statistical stuff we need to build
like these profiles of cheaters that we
can then just analyze and it just takes
time you know with your metadata we have
holy [ __ ] yeah I have wonder yeah if the
ultimate way is to just if there's some
kind of way to detect them in the game
if like they're moving too fast or
shooting like we do have that but it's
just it just takes time to review all
this and like what you can't do well you
can do automatic stuff but there could
be situations where like you're driving
a car and you go off a cliff and then
suddenly you trigger that because you're
going at that's
for an X amount of time so these are the
conceptions that you have to and you
know if you roll this out then you may
be banning thousands of people
incorrectly and you really have to be
careful so we do have like our team
killing report feature is now kind of
complete we spent about two months
analyzing team killing and then now we
have this kind of model and system we
rolled out that you can report people
and people will get auto banned if they
team kill too much you know so the
system that was in place same with
hacking it just takes time to really
kind of get these systems written you
know because they don't exist yet right
I notice your your man that's lived in
many places a few you currently live in
South Korea yeah which is where blue
hole is located right yeah yeah you were
you live in Brazil as you mentioned
you're Irish yeah so what do you what do
you think of these places another great
yeah Brazil is wonderful like don't
expect anything done in a hurry you know
Brazil very relaxed they they work to
live basically you know once they finish
working they live and they're wonderful
wonderful be I lived well outside like
the big cities in a small city and
they're just lovely
you know welcoming and great people
right curry is the same you know in in
Korea the first few weeks I was there
I'd have dinner at the company every
night and then going home I'd go and get
cookies or something and coke and the
Via della or the the store beneath my
apartment and the old woman there that
would serve me every day like when there
was like rice I was like what rice I was
like yes I like rice and she got me like
this dinner because she thought all I
was eating was cookies it's okay you
know they're very welcoming very
friendly like there's no crime there at
all right that's funny I've heard in
South Korea they're very racist and not
warm to white people
oh no there's that not even your
experience oh they never have that
problem
I think somebody think it's like some of
the older generation may be a little bit
like that huh but you know they speak
English in South Korea a lot um some do
yeah I mean it's taught in schools but
you know most of the people I work with
that speak a little bit they get very
shy for speaking because anywhere
speaking correctly right but most of
them do speak a little
I've heard that Brazil is kind of a
dangerous place I've always wanted to
visit but I
I've heard no I mean you go to like Rio
San Paulo the big cities it's a little
shady in some of the areas right but
then you've got like any major yeah but
then you go outside like to like where I
lived or you know some of these really
beautiful little towns there's no crime
there you know you get to see some
proper extreme poverty but very there is
crime but you know not you're not gonna
get mugged on the street you know what I
mean it's it's it's a great place to
visit what were you doing went for work
when you're living in it and Brazil
photography designing websites print
stuff and DJing every night like 20
years what kind of music does Korea it's
mainly deep house all right boy and like
my disco but in Brazil I played like a
lot of like progressive house and stuff
just because I was the Irish DJ right
that would come in from Harlan right so
I played the big room house and stuff
but I love my deep house and disco but
I've been doing it like 20-something
years so started with vinyl moved to CDs
now I have the the DDJ sx2
[ __ ] beautiful piece of kit and
you're gonna have to throw a party
someday so let's go back to you were in
Brazil developing this mod yeah for
originally ARMA 2 ARMA 2 and was it
wasn't very successful then yeah I mean
it was a big mod I mean it wasn't like
so I had I could afford 6 servers ok how
did you make money and people bought the
mod no no it's all free unevenness how
did you make money back I don't didn't
make money from the moment was all just
providing you a game like I would ask
for donations every now and again just
to pay for servers but in general I
would never push for donations ever you
know it's just like here's a game mode
enjoy it and like when I first launched
an ARMA 2 it was like I had 6 servers
and they filled up in seconds what like
that cost if you don't mind oh not very
expensive it was like $100 $100 per
month for a server that would host two
or three games you know so it wasn't
that it may be $200 a month okay but as
well I was getting sponsorship from not
sponsorship but
like some server companies would give me
a few servers as I put their name at the
start so I had that the star that's cool
yeah you you were building recognition
people knew who you were and they liked
your servers and then from ARMA 2 you
went where - its ARMA 3 because so I was
about three months doing at an ARMA 2 I
know maybe bit longer six months in arma
2 can remember so long ago now this is
about four years five years ago but I -
Daisy the standalone came out so at that
stage you know everyone kind of left out
royale I'm Daisy
and went to play the dayz standalone so
at that stage I kind of decided rice
let's move over to arma 3 arma 3 was out
of beta at that stage it was relatively
stable and I thought ok I can move it
over here and really try to like pare
down the battle royale game-mode and
that's where like interested about Rory
again mode that everyone knows today was
kind of born you know when the red zones
yeah that was in ARMA 2 it had zombies
that had like if you were outside the
zone and ARMA 2 it just spawned zombies
on you so you see people running into
the zone with like a trail of twenties
army yeah you know we had something like
three four hundred zombies on the map so
was I kind of a fun little twist oh yeah
no I mean I'd love to do it again you
know we have our zombie mode now and in
custom games as if I need another reason
against scared shitless playing pub G
it's just like it was great this is like
having players play a zombies you mean
it's just cuz players are clever you
know right right there's one there's a
video was it Jack frags did that just
for them and there's like 40 zombies
left and the disown you can see all
around you right and they're like where
the hell are they and then suddenly they
all stand up in the grass and it's just
that way oh yeah like this for a zombie
just stand opens like okay yeah it was
fun so you so you went to ARMA 3 yeah
then you're well how popular were your
armies magazine kind of popular so ARMA
3 I had it speak ARMA 3 had like 60
games online at any one time we had like
a peak player count at one stage of
about a thousand CCU which for a mod was
at that time it just just doing it I was
on like
social welfare in Ireland at this time I
moved back to Ireland I was on social
welfare and was paying for the servers
with social welfare Wow and it was like
you know I was kind of I'd ask for
donations every now and again but for
the most part it was like you know I we
tried to pay for the servers myself so
Thank You Ireland by the way they have
some right but no so yeah then I did
that that was about another six months
in ARMA 3 and lyric and then those guys
were playing it and that's when the h
one thing happened it was like the end
of that year the-- was 2014 it was just
before h1 launched where Adam Clegg who
was a big fan of lyric had seen lyric
playing Battle Royale on ARMA 3 and
thought this is great this would be a
great addition to our game and he got
John Smedley to reach out to me and h1z1
battle royale was kind of spawned from
that and that was another one of your
great yeah so I went it was the most
popular one before yeah Bob gene so I
kind of I went to San Diego for about
three weeks before they launched and I
just worked with Adam and Jimmy wasn't
huntin and a few of the other team to
really just kind of company a unique
idea for their game and you know they
kind of wanted to simplify it a lot so I
let them roam with it and over the
coming year I kind of you know that was
their version about Royale you know they
license my idea but it was their version
so I let them kind of run with it and I
kind of move back to ARMA 3 that's there
all right let's touch back on that more
we're gonna take a short commercial
break guys we will be right back with a
Breton and green see you guys soon thank
you to hims for sponsoring this episode
of the H Street podcast thanks to
science baldness is now an option in
fact I've been taking hims for years
that's actually not true but I would if
I needed it and someday I might here's
the deal you guys don't let genetics get
in the way of having a big beautiful
flowing mane of hair we have got for
hims calm a one-stop shop for hair loss
skin care sexual wellness for men this
is basically everything you you're your
dick is gonna get harsher and your hair
is gonna get longer this is it this is
the godom package this is gonna make you
look at life and say got him that's for
hims calm this is FDA
approved well-known generic equivalent
to name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your dank hair it's not a verbal
it's not an herbal supplement
prescription solutions are backed by
science there's no waiting room no
awkward doctor visits real like hey Doc
my dick don't work wrong conversations
go
what are you it's embarrassing forget
that just go to for hims calm and all
the sudden a little shot of life and
hair you know I'm saying there's no
awkward doctor's visit save you hours by
going to four hems com answer a few
quick questions doctors will review and
prescribe you and it's gonna get
directly delivered to your door okay
listen
order now my listeners get a trial month
of everything you need to keep your hair
for just five dollars right now while
supplies last
see website for full details this would
usually cost you a hundred bucks if you
went to a doctor's office or pharmacy so
go to four hems dot-com /h tree that's
fo r hims com /h three four hems comm /h
three four all of your mail needs all of
them for hims thank you to them for
sponsoring us up next we've got nature
box and as a big boy I get so excited
when I talk about nature box because as
a big boy I don't necessarily want to be
a bigger boy but I love snacks and
that's where nature box comes in okay
now listen up
nature box has over a hundred delicious
snacks all made with high-quality simple
ingredients that means no artificial
colors flavors or sweeteners it's easy
just go to naturebox.com/tyler box we'll
deliver deliver them right to your door
now here's what they're about they're
about making the highest quality most
delicious snacks varied new every month
that's healthy to eat and taste great
now where can you find that tell me I've
been trying to find that my whole life
and look at me look what it's done to me
not anymore this is what nature box does
to me we
and I still love snacks the beautiful
thing clearly it hasn't done that to me
because I just sucked in my stomach but
give me give me a couple months do my
best all right new snacks are added
every month inspired by new food trends
professional chefs and customer feedback
there's no risk if you don't like the
snack naturebox will replace it for free
so my question is what do you have to
lose all right
the holidays mean one thing go go go you
got presents to wrap
travel plans relatives of brace for with
all that it can be hard to find that
time to eat healthy let nature bucks
help with snacks that are both delicious
and better for you and right now nature
box is offering h3 fans yes 50% off your
first order when you go to
naturebox.com/tyler how much was that
5-0 unbelievable that's half Wow that's
naturebox.com/tyler 50% off your first
order nature box calm
give them a shot it's risk-free if you
don't like it there replace it it's
delicious
you're gonna love it get those sriracha
nuts cashews get those coconut cashews
get those dried pineapple chips please
Thank You nature box for sponsoring us
and we've got della shave club we all
know and love Dollar Shave Club they've
got amazing razors for just a few bucks
I've been a member I love my razor I
love my razor it's got its meaty it's a
weighty razor it glides over you like a
like a curling puck over ice in a
professional Olympic match you ever
watched curling you see those lunatics
with the broom it's like that but you
don't need the broom it just glides does
that mean is that a good analogy I guess
it glides okay you're going straight to
the Olympics of curling with this Dollar
Shave Club methi you get the point okay
but what you didn't know is that Dollar
Shave Club also has products for pretty
much everything else in the bathroom
body wash shampoo hair gel lip balm and
yes you guessed it butt wipes one wipe
Charlies they call them it's so
effective you just need one star
with the wet start dry and wet that's my
philosophy you know get in there clean
up the toxic waste zone and then you
bring bringing the wet tools and that's
where you really clean up right you love
found it yeah that good I'm talking
about at the store there's so many
options you can't tell the difference
between antiva then if you really have
questions of course don't know what
they're talking about so what's the
point of waste your time ask you note
Dollar Shave Club makes it easy and
convenient for to upgrade your shave and
your bathroom now you don't have to step
foot in a story a high-quality shave and
grooming products they deliver them
right to your door and if you're like me
and I know you are you're lazy is 4f
because you're probably playing Zelda or
Mario or some other crap and you don't
have to get what you got to put on shoes
you got to put on clothing you got to
drive to the store get real it's like a
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
it's like you're too lazy to go to the
store to get the shaves and then you're
unshaven so you don't want to go to the
store cut through the crap and get it to
your door if you're like me you're sick
of the nonsense all right try Dollar
Shave club's [ __ ] shower shave starter
kit for new members it's only 5 bucks
ok this features their executive razor
and 3 trial side version the most
popular product that helps you stay
fresh and clean and your first box you
received there shave butter body wash 1
wipe Charlies butt wipe who's Charlie
he's got a liability he's like that
would be interesting he's like I'm so
passionate about this butt wipe I'm
putting my name on it like he was not
like Charlie's razor you know what I
mean he's like I love these bot wipes
this is Juwan wipe Charlies anyway tip
of the beanie to Charlie whoever you are
you will also receive their executive
razor which includes their premium
weighty handle and a focused set of
cartridges after the first box
replacement cartridges are sent for only
a few bucks a month this offer is
exclusively available at
dollarshaveclub.com slash HP that is
Dollar Shave Club dot-com slash h3 if
you want a great gift give them Dollar
Shave Club they got a super simple gift
membership and he cards Dollar Shave
club's high quality product we'll have
you covered from face to cheeks and you
know what end
cheeks I was just about to make a joke
like you know what cheeks were talking
about but they wrote it in about cheeks
oh yeah they covered me on that there's
no better time to try the club out so
thank you to a Dollar Shave Club hymns
and naturebox for supporting us if
you're in the market for Anglos products
please consider supporting them to help
support the show now let's get right
back into the memes with our boy player
unknown aka brain and green
welcome back everybody safety podcast we
were just talking about you were back
making mods for h1z1 or at least you had
licensed it
yeah ID license the idea and kind of
helped them implant the first idea of
battle royale into the game and then
they kind of took the idea and ran with
it which eventually spawned king of the
kill last year for this year is it that
when you started making actually money
from this project yeah no I mean John
Smedley really made sure you know they
like gave me a good license and and he
really made sure that like he said to me
he's like you know you've been doing
this for a few years for free now I want
to give you a chance to make some money
from this because you've done something
good that's really great and I mean that
doesn't happen you know yeah the whole
exchange is interesting because well one
so the format is something that you own
is it something like you consider IP so
how did he come to license it from you
yeah but that's what his lawyers thought
as well he was like yeah yeah well no I
even thought it was just they they found
their the concept of licensing an IP to
be interesting right but it's the same
like a blue hole they did the same they
license my game mode they they like you
know accepted about Royale at least in
the version that I created for ARMA 3
was kind of my IP and they licensed that
for use in battlegrounds you know so I
get a license fee from them as well so
much the same way that like dota 2 is
Allah is a license yeah I thought that
Valve bought young the guy who made it
icefrog I think it's something like that
yeah yeah it's like so this is great
thing if you don't know dota 2 was
created as a mod for Warcraft 3 oh my
this crypt by this guy I strong and it
became like it's all about bought it the
license for it so it's probably the
biggest games in the last 10-15 years
have been mods you know it's like do you
see
your game potentially being the
birthplace of something else oh maybe I
would love to find an ex-player oh no
like really I mean it's or do you think
that year will be too restrictive or out
of paranoia of not wanting to expose the
engine well no I mean Thea's our custom
game mode can really let people play
with the game like we as I said we
really want to give fine-grained control
but mainly done from like UI elements so
that you you're at least doing it in the
game and not ik modeling the game
externally you know which is yes it is
restrictive but you know I hope that
people will be able to create the wrong
game I was using this and and and it
opens up to a lot more because for me
modding was like you know this massive
mountain you know you had to not too
cold and make marvels and all this kind
of stuff and I really want to give
everyone a chance to create their own
game mode without having to worry about
learning to code or I'll tell you I
there's so much potential in there for
custom games like looking back on
Starcraft 2 some of the stuff that came
out of there was just so weird and Wow
like our defenses oh yeah and this kind
of so I would love to see that or a 3d
environment and pub G some that guy did
like Delta Force Black Hawk Down I
played that game for years and I love
the custom servers you know because
you'd have like a tunnel war where it's
just a big long tunnel right anyway like
two teams of 20 exactly souls again just
a mojito other down in a little tunnel
ya know this kind of stuff is that
something that it's gonna be possible
with I hope so I mean that's what I want
I want people to be able crave whatever
game-mode they want not just restricted
to you know Battle Royale but it's it's
a platform for game modes right it's
gonna take us some time to do that but
yeah so first of all let's start here
the game releases officially for us it's
just a big milestone it's it means for
us that the game what we see is mainly
future complete right that all the
elements of the game mode of like the
game are in there for the most part
especially when it comes to gameplay so
like we have the 3d replays in we have
the killcam or or death cam in there we
have a few other like all the features
that we kind of said we were gonna put
in are there now okay that's where we
can see it okay now it's time to you
know polish the out game add character
leveling out these kind of polished
systems and sort of superfluous systems
that aren't necessary for
play but just are nice to have so it's
so much like the dota2 really stay if
you recall that nothing really changes
yeah I mean it's just like hey we did it
well no I mean we have the test server
moving to live so like we have the new
map coming in we have oh the new maps
not out yet no it's not on the live
servers so it's only on the tester okay
so coming out tonight oh yeah yeah oh
interesting to be on live so we have the
new map the optimization is much better
you know it runs a lot man that's coming
tonight that's a lot of meaningful oh
yeah no I mean not only is it just it's
like for us internally it's a milestone
it's a big milestone but you know it
doesn't mean the end of development you
know we want a course but you know yeah
the game is technically oh no it's
coming for the players 3d replays new
map much better optimization like people
are seeing upwards of like 30 40 FPS
sometimes in some systems now so and
both maps are running much better now
not just the new map so you know we
still have a lot of work to do with
servers and stuff like that and there
will be issues but the core game on the
client-side should be running a lot
smoother now so you know I'm with the 3d
replays I'm so excited for that you know
it's like people have seen it already on
the the test servers where they're
making little movies basically you know
because you can watch your whole round
back and I want expand that I want to
put cinematic tools so you can create
movies using you around or your friends
round or you know and I think it's gonna
be really powerful for I'm really put in
some really cool cinematic stuff in
there that yeah you can give it a look
or a feel or whatever it's cool yeah I'm
curious so you you you have this battle
royale format that you've licensed now
twice to bigger developers so how tell
me about how this relationship with blue
hole worked or first of all how did you
guys meet and how did you start to
conceive of making your own actual game
so Chang and Kim are CEO now he was
executive producer of blue hall at the
time and he had been making mmo's as
most Korean companies had make or just
MMORPGs that's what they're a but he
loved Battle Royale the movie it was a
big fan and he always wants to make
about Roy a style game and he had seen
the work I'd done an h1 and then ARMA
and he thought okay let's reach out to
him and see if he wants to make a game
with us so they sent me an email and I
got on a Skype call with him and then
Sammy and we chatted for about
an hour or so and then the next week I
was on a plane to Korea to meet the team
and I saw the concepts they'd done and I
just loved the quality and the level of
detail they put in I thought okay you
know that was my main concern for making
my own game was that it would have like
this level of quality and and this you
know it looked like a modern game that's
what it was important to because I like
my realism in games so that was
important I saw what they had done on on
Terra and I saw just their attention to
detail and like their motto of like
making well-made games and that just
room and I thought something inside
isn't yeah this is the right call to
make and went and they offer me position
as creative director leading a team you
know that's the start the team knew I
didn't have a huge amount of experience
and they they really did support me well
and kind of we had a lot of arguments
about things adding to the game but you
know it's you know I learned a lot over
thatthat first like two or three months
because ya was my first job in gaming
right here be creative director right
okay so what was the size of the team at
the time was like 30 people you know it
was really small it was like this core
group of devs that have been longtime
friends of CH and I'm just you know
being on his team for many years and you
know just yeah it was about 30 people we
even open till launch
that's a steam early access I think we
reached a maximum size of about 40
people you know 35 40 we had about five
people working off-site remotely and
about 35 people now can 130 years I'm
growing you know we just moved into new
offices in Korea in Seoul and they're
just beautiful big lot of space and you
can see the true size of the team now
and and it excites me and you know we
have an office opening in in LA we have
one in Madison Wisconsin and we have one
in Europe opening as well and I'm just
seeing that kind of growth really
excited because I know this is like you
know we're not this is not like a pump
and dump
yes sir people have said you know it
like this is something like I can see
our internal plan I can see that this is
something we want to support for 10 20
years and that really excites me because
that's all I ever wanted from a game was
that we make a good game and give
something good for players to play right
how hard is it to find good people fast
because you guys 30 to 130 it's really
hard to find people like I mean we're
we're in the position now we'll work
trying to find people for a fashion
company we started recently and we've
been looking for like a month and it's
super hard to find qualified people I
imagine it's the same way and exactly
like in in Korea especially a lot of the
game developers want to work on mobile
games because that's where the money is
it's like Mobile in in the Far East is
super super popular you know everyone
and their mother and their dog is on
their phone so you know there's huge
money there so allows developers want to
work in mobile space rather than PC
space you know because it's not a hugely
profitable industry so finding these
people who have number one the necessary
skills know the engine and can fit with
the team it's hard let's see not a lot
of people know and again it's not
something you can just throw money out
you know it's like you have to spend
time and I think people just think that
you're like just throw money oh yeah you
guys have made this amount of money
obviously you can do anything and it's
like no the world doesn't work like that
you know it takes time if you want to
make something good a text time so you
as the creative director what exactly is
your role in the game what do you
oversee what what authority do you have
cuz I know a lot of people basically
blame you yeah or give you all the
credit for the game you oh yeah both
sides right III my Apple to making the
game by myself
yeah I'm the creative director so mainly
for me and this was kind of a tough
adjustment for me because when I did the
mod I had like a small team working with
me but at the start I did everything you
know I did from coding to the art
everything was kind of my hand and I
oversaw everything and then coming into
being creative director where you're
essentially a visionary and not like an
implementer as they say it's that was
tough because I felt myself
micromanaging a lot and I was kind of
given out to a few times it's like stop
booking like imagine it's like so you
know really it's just I apply envision
and then the team make the vision which
is strange to me because a great place
to be
oh yeah but it's straight because I like
to work I like to get my hands for years
your word would your taste it's probably
hard to it oh yeah convey it to someone
else but I mean I'm really lucky like
the team we have now that's why I'm
happy to travel around because I know I
can trust them you know it's like
leading up to launch I know I don't need
to worry I don't need to approve
anything like everything they send me
I'm like yeah that's great you know that
they have such a high quality bar anyway
that I you know they're easy to work
with
but you know date today it's I do mostly
I am the face of the game essentially no
but really it's the team you know they
make the game you know and they fix the
game and they do everything with the
game you know I
while yes I oversee some stuff and give
a yes or no really my job now is
creating the next vision and kind of
like where we go in the future how
quickly did success come from the moment
you guys put it up on Steam and what
alpha say yeah we did like we did like
this pre alpha back in June last year
which no one should have played it was
like a prototype it's the kind of
version of a game that companies never
show it's an internal play test and we
decided you know to hell with it we got
six hundred streamers people who'd
supported battle royale and on h1 and
ARMA and kind of said listen come try
this out and it was rough you know it
was really rough but it was just the
concept and then for the first alpha
testing we just opened it up streamers
and said here listen go stream the game
you know let's show people this
evolution you know let's show people the
the birth of a game essentially was it
all the clout you had built up over the
years you think that gave it that
sparkle like oh I think so I mean I was
I've always been very helpful to
streamer especially in the ARMA 3 battle
royale like if they wanted servers for
for custom like sub Sundays or something
I would give them I would host servers
for them you know a lot of them I gave
like 50 or 60 streamers like The
Observer tool so they could just go in
and watch the end of matches and you
ended up having great joke casters being
born out of that so you know it was I
was very friendly with streamers and I
never asked them for anything you know I
just here's a game if you like it you
can play it you know I never kind of
chased people to play my game you know
at what point did it like explode though
because for me it just happened like a
couple of months ago where it was just
like yeah yeah no I mean I I think like
we had a very good launch you know we
were think million copies sold in like
16 days or something so well the
beginning oh yeah no it was like we were
just going like this start which that's
incredible and it was it's surreal to us
and I think it's great that it happened
like that because it was so surreal it
didn't really sink in you know the team
it just were focused on making the game
you know we're not out celebrating you
know for every year we were sad like we
we were doing like a dinner for every
million copies we sold
but they have to stop that because that
was going out right so then it was like
okay very 10 million copies right and
then we go out for a dinner with the
whole team have some drinks and then
it's back to work you know we're very
you know there's no celebrate even me
like I'm not running around the place
like popping champagne and you know just
that's not what I do it's I like working
so before you were honest true
shoestring you are welfare oh you know
the game was literally funded by welfare
now you've all pretty much all the
resources you could ask for in terms of
money yeah how has that changed the
development of the game oh really I mean
it the development plans still is in
place you know we're we're still trying
to we've had a plan for you know this
year and now 1.0 was kind of that plan
is now done and now we move to next year
and you know building it as a platform
for eSports and and all this kind of
other work we have to do like character
leveling and all these other systems we
want to add the Polish to the game and
you know we still want to plan what we
want to do for the next year so you know
that's after we get one point out the
door we sit down and do more meetings
and try to figure out what we want to do
next year so yeah has the money enable
you to do something more with the game
that you previously didn't think oh this
is what I mean volting for example you
know like when we we didn't put that in
early access launch because we didn't
have the funds to get the people to
program it or the time to do it really
that's the other thing like is it that
hard to program just like the mechanic
oh yeah at the window oh is it seems so
simple obviously to a layman yeah so you
have to first get the vaulting
animations which meant is going to
Prague and capturing mocap for about a
day and a half and then you import that
into the game that's another process of
like actually tweaking and stuff like
that then the animators do and then you
have to write the system so our map is
not built for vaulting a lot of maps are
built with walls right right our map was
never had vaulting in mind so we had to
build a system that was dynamic that
like it scans the geometry in front of
you and then analyzing okay this is this
high and to get that working smoothly
took about three months of that's know
and even like each animation has say
let's say 10 states and every state has
X amount of animation so like every
animation may have like a hundred
different you know actions within it and
doing all that it just it's in an
ordinate of time you know and to get it
run smoothly and that doesn't send
people to space you know
right it's a that can be true for every
game because we simple act of jumping
out the window
but it's just because the game was
already made without a mine exactly so
we have to like challenge yeah we had to
make a dynamic system that worked with
the environment rather than the
environment working with the vaulting
system but it's great because now the
system means that we don't have to worry
about making the map specifically Volta
ball you know that those vaulting system
will work that we have a lot of freedom
when we come to designing the map that
we can design it whatever way we want
and the vaulting will just working right
here's a question from our sub rat that
was a good one what is your view on the
influence of early access models of the
gaming industry as a whole I mean
obviously you guys used it to incredible
effect but there are less scrupulous
developers who can take people's money
and run off with it so I've heard this
before and I really don't think it's the
case you know yeah obviously there's
some dodgy developers but a lot of like
making games is hard you know it's like
the act of making game is not something
that should be undertaken lightly you
know this is there's something strange
about selling a game before it's like
finish I think first like for
multiplayer games you know it's if you
want to build a competitive shooter and
again it's balance you need players you
know getting QA teams is expensive and
you know having a massive amount of QA
testers you know that play your game on
a daily basis it gets it gets to balance
the game much quicker you know I think
really testing it I like it you want to
build a game with a community if your
game is community focused it's a really
good way of doing it but you know I
think a lot of developers got a lot of
slack and I think it's you know when
you're making a game you might come
across a problem that you can't fix
right and that you don't the knowledge
to fix and that will screw your budget
and then you're over budget and then
you've no money left and then you can
update the game anymore
and you know it's like I've seen some
guys like there's a guy who's bringing
out game I met at e3 called coma and
he's worked on it like for four years by
himself right and it's he's now finally
getting it finished like games are hard
and I think a lot of people don't
understand that when they're getting
into making a game which is why I think
early access is a great way to build
your game with a community but you know
it's it's hard to make games and I think
a lot of consumers don't understand that
sure sure
I mean it's a Kickstarter for a game in
a way that's a more practical and real I
mean even the kickstart
I see some Kickstarter's and then the
figure they put up is so low you know
you're looking at that going I'll get
you a quantum computer for $10,000 or
something yeah oh yeah yeah yeah that'll
get you but you know three months of
work you know and then if you don't get
the game finished in three months what
are you gonna to know that it's yeah
making games is hard
it's a long process it really is like we
we did it in a year I didn't believe we
do it in a year you know but now we you
know we wanted to get something out in a
year that people could actually play and
give us feedback on and we did that and
then you know we're now we're launching
one point Owen and I think like the test
server build is pretty stable you know
there's a few crash issues but we'll fix
those you know and it's in a good State
so like I'm really happy at the state of
the game right now but again it's not
finished
you know we serve lots to do but it's a
milestone yeah I was looking at this
list today oh yeah that is I love this
list it's fascinating time this is the
top most selling games of all time yep
this is great you guys cracked into this
list we did before release year I think
you're like number 24 but the numbers
only cuz I wanted to know compare you
guys sold about 25 million companies and
I wanted to compare that up against
other one Tetris first of all I'm a set
Swiss fan I love Tetris it unbelievable
that is great so this guy or this
developer is getting royalties on every
single in those sales again is there's
one guy that made Tetris is he I know
there was a mod story behind that that's
like you know someone copied his game
first and released it and he made no
money from add and then whoever did that
could have been deal ah listen it's
going to happen you know it's the world
today like it just like you could have
someone could have just burned you or
like blue hole oh yeah the game without
you and incredibly lucky that I've have
managed to work with really good people
like even my boss see a cheese honestly
my one of the most honorable and honest
men and he's not afraid to tell you what
he thinks you can own Tetris well I
could have I just I think I'll be going
to my grave I can smell it see obviously
the the story of how these guys all
reached out to you respectfully to
license review is pretty pretty
incredible okay I mean it doesn't happen
right I feel so lucky that I've been
given this chance you know and I finally
got to make it again
with someone and I'm just happy people
enjoy it yeah it's right number 2
minecraft now that what do we got here
122 million minecraft is catching up
with Tetris then this one actually blew
105 well they would they sell a lot of
copies in console I would think a lot
that's one of those games have bought
like three times in heaven pleasure I
mean I go buy it on the computer I'm
like I'll play it on xbox okay but
anyway you go down down Diablo 3 my
goodness mm-hmm I just
Oh Diablo 3 make an appearance in Skyrim
making it appearance Wii Sports that's
so kind of a twist isn't it we sports
resorts no less uh they must have just
included that with every week and there
it is number 21 one down loo hole bro no
this is from 2017 or early access 24
million unbelievable how does that make
you feel I mean that's kind of surreal
right that's exactly it
well you look at that number go okay no
it's bizarre to me you know and they I
never expected I think no one expected
what we've seen but it's a credit to the
team you know they've made such an
amazing product that I just you've gone
kind of and over and I mean kind of
overnight right and in terms of wealth
kind of you because you saw it you said
in the first month or 16 days you sold a
million oh yeah but like I don't get
that money but you get license fees yeah
I get a small percentage you know love
all that I mean but you know it I don't
make a massive amount of money sure I'm
comfortable which is great you know and
for me it's more important that I have a
daughter so now she doesn't need to
worry you know I can ensure whatever she
wants that you can do now and then that
for me is the most for me I don't care
you know it's it's likely those people
maybe even assume that you make more
money than you do oh yeah but we've got
has this immediate wave of wealth and
success had an effect on your life no
like I say like I like wine so I can now
enjoy a nice bottle of wine but I don't
like you know I don't they spend money
you know I don't see them
I'm not a label junkie I don't like you
know flashy things I would rather no one
knows who I am you know it's that's who
I am I'm not extravagant you had
mentioned that you were staying at a
nice hotel in LA and they keep asking
you if you if are you sure you stay here
no every time I walk in is like are you
staying here sir I was leaving right and
said goodbye to the lady and then we
came back literally like an hour later
excuse me things like I said goodbye to
you like 10 minutes what can you do
you've got a that's the best way to
success I'll never forget some comedian
said it you know why people like Bill
Gates will always be rich because look
at look at Bill Gates he still Shops at
Costco this but not just still walking
around with this fedora i bless his soul
you know tip of the fedora to him I was
gonna ask now now that you have become
successful in that way what what have
you treated yourself to what's the
nicest thing I'm what's the nicest thing
you've on just this game so there's a
name from France Kol domain level remain
Conti they make red wine and it's
honestly just the best red wine in the
world and I've read many things about
this and everyone that says it's like it
is just amazing
and like new bottles of this come in at
they sometimes started like 5 10 grand a
bottle right for this right oh no its
proper I use it from oh no II these are
New Year's like you know suntan G [ __ ]
they just know how to make great wine so
I saw one on a menu I was in London for
the video game awards and I went for
dinner at this like one-star Michelin
place and they had we were having beef
wellington and they had a bottle of
Richburg which is just one of their
thing and it was about running about
4,000 sorry no no the whole no III lie
it was about two and a half yeah there's
two enough because a whole meal yeah
it's still a number no really it did not
taste like red wine it did not say it
tasted like this fruity juice or gray
really just the depth of flavor and
there was no alcohol
who is just smooth and even like finer
Richburg Richburg if you want to sponsor
our they'll be happy to give you aid
yeah my party who doesn't really like
red wine she loved it you know that it's
it's just this different taste but again
you know yeah that's kind of what I've
done for myself just a bottle of wine I
know but like I mean I thought my dad a
car and thank God my house you know
I'll buy things for my family and stuff
I left for me I don't really care you
know it's like as long as I'm
comfortable in can eat I'm okay right
what do you eat what's your favorite
thing ramen old is there a level of like
ramen in terms of price can you get
extra have again with Ron oh no I don't
think so
it's just a street food yeah like I mean
the best ramens I've had have been in
really done done or dingy places in
Japan where like they've got mold inside
the wall I I was watching some Travel
Guide for food and they were there's
actually a ramen place that has a
Michelin star enjoy man that's just like
street food yeah there's lines outside
the door all day it has a Michelin star
there's one in Singapore as well where
it's like this Hong Kong fried chicken
or something and you know he's got a
Michelin star I think comes and puts on
his chef's whites I said before I even
got it like he puts a chef sorry that's
why it's at 5:00 in the morning to fry
the dark and stuff like that it's like
but they got a Michelin star it's
quality yeah totally about the quality
Japan interestingly has the most
Michelin stars of any country by far the
great can't for like 60 70 percent of
all the Michelin stars I've been to a
few I was a few hours of out a few in
Netherlands and in Yan England I've been
a few in there just especially the to
star in three-star places holy we got
our first million subscribers on our
YouTube channel
LeBaron India it's crazy right it's like
Bali it's like it is it is the service
is unbelievable there was someone under
there like fondling my balls I didn't
know but like you
it was obviously really expensive but
they serve you like a plate of raw
salmon and I don't like fish right and
they've got some kind of sauce going on
there
and you eat it and it is the best fish
you've ever had fresh not fishy it's
incredible and you're like oh my god
okay I get this I love summon them yeah
and this and this $500 per person
restaurant yeah I brought a friend of
mine to LA for Christmas a few
Christmases ago and he loves Mexican
food and my brother fish tacos here and
he just fell in love and then he came
back to Ireland and went into a local
like Mexican place and got a fish taco
he said I sat there and cried we're
friends of Mexican food that's like our
favorite thing yeah and we did a lot
here but when we lived in Israel
together huh which ride once the Mexican
place there oh they have Mexican places
in Korea as well don't ever eat Mexican
outside I would say Texas or SoCal no
all in all of Cal all in California yeah
keep looking a bit so angry they said
that we're in the United States all
right SoCal but like you go MX Aaron
Israel they're like oh my god they made
like a burrito and they put corn and
they really don't belong there
yeah it was a mess shame on you I don't
just find a Mexican guy he'll tell you
what to do they gotta like put their
little twist on every time it it's
sacrilege mm-hmm it's really good fun
Israel guys we're gonna take a quick
commercial break is it calm down I'm
fired up about these anyway guys quick
commercial break
we've got a ton of chit chat left so
don't go away stay tuned see you soon
thank you to kaptara for sponsoring this
episode of a Street podcast it's that
time of the year when the days are
shorter don't waste your precious
daylight sifting through a sea of search
results when looking for the right
business software get home on time
tonight with kaptara
dot-com now cap tears a website if you
are a young entrepreneur if you have an
entrepreneurial spirit I like saying
that it's a fun phrase it's very lofty
and I I think that I have an
entrepreneurial spirit do you illa I
think you definitely do I think you
embody the spirit of entrepreneurial
know that I could say to everybody
myself yeah I don't know what that means
I just hear them say on Shark Tank oh
yeah yeah and I'm trying to glorify just
so I'm talking there's a camera anyway
get focused we can you can we can we get
sponsored by some ADHD medicine or
something Kat Tara is the point of this
okay they have a website for young
entrepreneurs with entrepreneurial
spirit where you can go there tell them
what exactly you need and they're gonna
describe to you the perfect software for
unions this is a valuable service I
cannot overestimate it okay talking
about editing I'm talking about business
I'm talking about bookkeeping anything
when you're start-up looking to keep
better tracks of customers and nonprofit
hoping to have record fundraising year
or business that simply needs better
payroll software you need kaptara and
you need the software that's on kaptara
search there are 400 categories of
software on kaptara discover the right
tool for your business
anything from email marketing to
scheduling to accounting and beyond
so far beyond it's so far beyond bro
kaptara makes it easy to find what
you're looking for
kaptara has thousands of ratings and
reviews from actual software users just
like you yes you they're just like you
not you the other guy best of all using
kept areas absolutely free 2018 will be
here before you know it so make sure
you've got the software your business
needs today to help you do what you do
better so here's the deal my friends
join the millions use kaptara that is
kaptara capt ER are a.com
let me try that again capt erra calm /h
tree that's kaptara with two R's comm /h
3 give them a try guys they got software
and beyond everything you need thank you
them for sponsoring us and finally
we have got the Elder Scroll legends my
favorite card game that I love okay now
if you are into card games if you are
like competitive edge if you want to get
weird and wild on the internet and
dominate fools in the freakin setting of
that Elder Scrolls everybody's favorite
franchise you need to get Elder Scrolls
legends it's free-to-play it's out on
everything Steam Mac iOS android tablets
phones here's what I love say you're on
your phone disconnect or you lose you
whatever use the battery dies forget
this log on your computer you can pick
up exactly where you left off no BS oh
you are gotta auto loss and get real
this we need we need games that evolved
for our taste in this new world of
gaming pound it you know that was all go
to Bethesda dotnet make an account and
works on all devices guys here's cool
thing twitch drops if you link your
Bethesda dotnet account with your twitch
account you get free stuff just for
watching someone streaming the game on
twitch pretty dope also unique features
of the game they've got Lane systems so
unlike other ones there's just one lane
you got two lanes it adds a whole new
depth of strategy to the game you got
monthly updates frequent meta game
patches they believe a digital card game
should make use of being digital and
have frequent changes what's the point
of being online if you can't be with the
times I mean really are we savages they
don't think so and I don't think so
either new card every goddamn month
you got runes prophecies color
attributes story mode PvE arena come on
why you wait why are you not playing
this right now the Elder Scrolls legends
here's a Skyrim search the Google Play
Store app store or steam to download for
free and play today visit bethesda net
for more information or go to beth dot
game slash h3 my friends you're gonna
have a lot of fun give it a shot it's
free to play this is the future and the
future is now and it's set in the world
of the Elder Scrolls which we all love
thank you guys thank you if you guys are
looking for new game consider playing
Elder Scrolls legends and if you're
looking for that perfect software
consider going to kaptara
to support the show my friends thank you
for watching let's get right back into
it
welcome back to the H Street podcast
I've got a question for you hmm
Mo Money mo problems so you become
somewhat of a gaming celebrity hmm I
think it's safe to say what does it feel
like having all these people you know
having opinions about you talking about
you blaming you for stuff people are
angry they get angry right yeah of
course you get everything I tried to
keep feet on the ground like I've been
dealing with the haste from like even
from way back an ARMA 3 you get just
tweets at you saying you know fix this
fix that this is broken this is ah you
know all the way through h1 and now into
Poggi so I enjoy it with coffee in the
morning you know I really like you know
any of like actually genuine comments I
get about like fix this because this is
broken right I'll pass on to the team
you know but if you're tweeting up me
going fix your [ __ ] game you know
that's useless you know a fix what right
so you just learned to ignore him it's
like oh you know what can you do right
yeah what can you do it's like I mean if
you'd if there are forums there are
places to their that tell us what your
problems are we will try to fix them we
love working with the community but just
tweeting a me going like fiction [ __ ]
games just right you know even it's
spread to my Instagram now I started
Instagram like Instagram man like leave
me alone is there any complaint or
comment that does bother you um when I
see commentators kind of like it
happened a few months ago when he was
saying this is a pump and dump you know
that like the only reason we were like
you know when we release the games come
create even though we're donating a
large amount of money to charity mm-hmm
people still say oh this just you know
that I was a you know a deceitful greedy
you know hypocritical it's it's gotta be
fresh encase your the face of the game
but you're not necessarily making the
no but I mean I take the heat that's
fine that's what I do you know I put my
name on the game you know it that's okay
but that's what it doesn't affect me
it's just like you know it's like I know
why we're doing this and you know with
you know especially when people said it
was a pump and dump it was like really
like you honestly think that like look
at our history of development you know
look at what we've done and you know
coming out of early access now when 21.0
it's like yeah you know it's like you
know people said oh this game will never
the amount of times I've heard that you
know it's like challenge accepted and
you know we're now [ __ ] challenge
completed and we're out of early access
how do you feel about microtransactions
because you guys did introduce your
crates but it's cosmetic
right purely cosmetic I mean cosmetic so
we did one for Gamescom just to test the
system you know we still have free
crates in the game and we still do and
you know it's we just wanted to test
system but I think cosmetic
microtransactions you know purely
cosmetic you know they're a good way to
keep the games alive as I said like we
spend millions of dollars per month on
servers you know we're not gonna be
selling millions of copies every week
anymore you know or it that the tears
that the the sales was slowly tail off
so you need some way to support the
massive costs of running a game for
millions of people you know and cosmetic
boxes work um I I personally I don't I I
don't know do people get angry about
cosmetic I don't think I don't know I
mean I think it's just when when they
start to react in the game that's when
people care and that's justified oh yeah
that shouldn't not never happen with us
you know our it's like for me it's I
like a skin economy I think you know it
rewards people like some guy sold the
player unknown set about a month ago and
he he bought himself a vive with real
scale and everything yes and that was
just from like you know buying good
looks huh and I love that I people tweet
me going thank you so much like I got
this you know it's like I like the
people get rewarded for playing the game
you know and this is something we want
to continue I've always been concerned
about skins in the game look if it's a
really bright color yeah it actually
makes it hinders you oh yeah if anything
the skins make you worse right yeah
there's more visible exactly there's a
guy in ARMA 3 we had this scientist
uniform that was all white it was just
white from top to tail like and overall
and he used to play as that just because
it was an extra challenge all right so
I'm sure you'll get people like running
around in the brightest things possible
just yeah it's like this saying in real
life like you gotta suffer to a good but
on the other end will you ever make
clothing that is more camouflaging by
nature oh no like we have a like an
internal rule that like we want to add
more camouflage clothing but it will be
found in game like oh so you can
actually find a habit changes clothing
in the game yes I would really want to
switch on yeah exactly so like we want
to put in maybe some military uniforms
to fight this you know just although
they never buy those no interests well
no I mean we don't want like we have
kind of a rule the artist of a rule that
you cannot make it kind of flies you
cannot make it like blending into the
surroundings too much you know as a
cosmetic item that will have a loot
crate's you know it's it's that to me is
pay to win and they understand it is a
little bit yeah and once you touch it
just a little bit then you can be
problematic exactly so you know we have
an internal rule about that so oh yeah I
mean it's what what in your opinion what
in your opinion is the perfect
competitive game or your opinion on what
your favorite competitive game out
either that's ever been made I'll OCS
you play a lot no I've tried playing but
I kept dying so I gave up
I'm really good it's going I'm really
awful it of you I'm really good at or
I'm really bad at both no really I mean
to the top three because I could come
you just know it's kind of hard and
that's how I got to know I loved was did
you see that twitch plays pokeo they had
the twitch shot controlling character
and he got to third position you know in
like this is twitch shock and so many
people got so mad because it's like I've
only ever gotten like to the top 20 and
twitch chat get to number three yeah I
know that you can reliably get top ten
if you just find a corner in the middle
of a circle and don't move yep if you
want to play like that yeah if you want
no fun but if you don't the great thing
about the game is that you can play
whatever you want
I mean it's if you want to run around
naked
the frying pan with a frying pan you
know I just tried waiting away that way
I think that will have to be an
achievement winning with just underwear
and frying pan when did you think about
this phenomenon of people chasing around
twitch streamers in jeeps honking it was
fantastic did you like oh yeah we're so
funny like everyone was like you know
please add horns the game please have a
merry play like play with discord like
I'd pop into the chart and this chord
and play with them and you know like
horn then we eventually added it and
then it was like please take the horns
every but it was fun for a while and you
know people were saying we were banning
people for for that we never banned
anyone for horn honking and a streamer
you know it was like there's so much
humorous got really really really oh
yeah they really did what would you say
to them chill the [ __ ] out
okay I mean look it's frustrating are
you sure I mean come on you know it's
not like you're competing for $100,000
and you know it's like right it's just
have a bit of fun like a little bit of a
delay it really troubles you that I mean
you can cover up the the the server ID
and supply that or black at the screen
until you're in the game you know
there's a few things extreme you say of
course they can't really know and I feel
like putting a delay will kind of ruin a
lot of people's dreams because that's
what twitch is about it's about that
interactivity it's adding the child and
I saw some complex hang you know I
thought they can't they're not
entertainers if they can't you know put
a delay and planes like come on you know
this is twitch you need that
interactivity you know and you have to
have that kind of that yeah their
interactivity with chat that's what
makes their their personality so
magnetic right I think you need to use
the hockey it's a laugh yeah I remember
this one guy he made this compilation of
harassing all these guys that was huge
on reddit and I don't remember the
streamer but he like took down the video
I'm not trying to [ __ ] on the sky or
anything but like um it was such a funny
video he was such a great video yeah and
I remember we were we're streaming pubs
you at the time and after that it was
just like honking mania and it's but
it's you're not covering yourself up to
like a lot of people if you let people
know where you're playing you know
expect us you know it's the internet um
yeah I will find you wait snipers you
need that you need to add like a horn or
something not you need to step it up to
the next level like a fog
we can put those in like as a DLC yeah
how do you feel about stream sniping is
that a problem where is that just it's
just okay that exists on Twitch it
exists like we we have internal systems
that we can look like if there's someone
that's really like malicious about it
you know we can we have data internally
we can see and go okay but this guy is
obviously it's an offense it's against
the rules of the game exactly right I
mean I mean we we handle it carefully we
don't ban people without evidence you
know a lot of people think we just ban
people on the word of streamers we don't
you know it's like we treat streamers
like everyone else we look at the report
if there's evidence there in our data
will bound for it you know when some
stream snipers you know they do it just
for fun but there's some that are
malicious and you know they will
literally follow around people to [ __ ]
up their day you know when you say
malicious what is it well no they're
literally like they're literally trying
to just kill the streamer every single
time so on their time exactly right and
I hate trolls
I [ __ ] hate like going back onto the
bridge you know what I mean it's like
you know especially like these guys are
trying to have a good time and you know
it's stop being a [ __ ] bully you know
what I mean it's so for me it's like we
have evidence we look up for evidence
and if there's evidence that we ban
people if not you know got it I want to
ask you about there's there's competing
battle royale games that are out do you
see them as copycats or natural
competition so I mean I don't see them
really as copycats you know there's like
there's certain things that I sort of
created for my battle royale game mode
in Arma and like you know jumping up a
plane and the red zone and stuff like
that these are kind of ideas that are
kind of unique and a lot of people said
no you know you copy just the movies and
stuff and they didn't exist in the
movies you know what I mean that these
are kind of unique to my game mode so
you know I feel some ownership over that
IP but certain aspects of your IP yeah
but like the Battle Royale game mode is
not something I create it's a Last Man
Standing deathmatch there you know I
want to it's more it's not the Battle
Royale aspect there's no part of your IP
that you feel you have possession of not
even possession but just something that
I came up with that's unique to my
battle royale game mode you know and
we've said this before that you know I
want this genre to grow we're not trying
to stifle anything by kind of
you know anything we've done the part
where we wanted to grow but in order for
the genre to go it has to have kind of
new and interesting spins you know if
it's all the same game every time
that's it boring right it's like you're
not getting anything new and we want to
kind of you know we want other companies
if they choose to do battle royale games
to put their own spin on it and try to
do something interesting instead of just
cloning what's popular
do you have intellectual property rights
some of that see this is like this is
thing we're looking into is that like in
movies and books and art that IP
protections exist you know if you're an
artist
there is protections in the medium right
for for you and it doesn't exist in
games right and people like say there's
a lot of game designers saying that it
would stifle creativity and survive that
but I don't think so you know I think it
would encourage creativity because
you're just not letting people just rip
off everyone else you know that you're
trying to give because games are art at
the end of the day and I you know I
think we should have some kind of
protection for artists essentially that
creates something unique and then they
they can kind of go forward with it
without worrying about someone just
going and ripping their idea that maybe
have a bigger budget you know so that's
what we want to look into is like
because it doesn't exist in this space
yet and I think it's something worth
looking into so your your perspective is
protecting because you guys are already
the but yeah I know I mean you don't
protect you we don't care like even
fortunate to kind of climb your way up
to the top without ever being ripped off
exactly right I mean we we we've had a
very good run and we're not trying to
stifle competition at all you know
listen you know the GTA 5 brought out
motor wars and you know the culling was
out before you know after we're not
trying to stop anyone you know what I
mean it's like we just want to like add
protections to stop you know you know as
I said like someone coming up with a
great idea maybe they aren't as popular
as us but then some other bigger
companies ripped off that idea you know
we want to provide protections for for
artists essentially you know because
they exist in all other mediums so why
not in games that sure that there's no
IP I guess there's like franchises
there's there's there's not like
mechanics I guess no exactly you know
there's like it I don't know exactly
that's a slippery slope to like it has
to be them care I know right like if
you're like okay let's just say
hypothetically we own parachuting out of
a airplane oh yeah in a battle royale
game like
we don't care I know it has to be done
carefully you know what I mean I but
it's something that I think is worth
looking into
not saying something that maybe will
work but it's definitely something that
I think artists have to be protected or
ideas have to be protected you know
because you're creating something unique
and especially nowadays where gaming is
getting so much more mainstream that you
know that you want the little guy to
succeed you know that if a little guy
creates something and then the bigger
company just rips off his idea you know
and he has no recourse or no framework
to to go to yes you know it can be very
a slippery slope but I think you know we
can look at as I said music and other
forms of art and see how they do it and
then you know work try to work something
out but you know it's it's a long road
it's you know something we need to look
into and research and talk with people
and talk with other industry people
about it you know it's not something we
want to jump into quickly but it's
something we think we should we should
look into mm-hmm that's I mean I on
YouTube the week we come home with a lot
of IP and intellectual property and
copyright stuff I mean there's a
philosophy I I somewhat agree with is
that there should be no copyright and
all i caught a crowd like the opposite
side is that I mean IP really some
people would argue just stifles
creativity yeah the best product wins
out right the best team the best
development wins out so there's I mean
that's that's one oh no I thought
personally I tend to agree with that you
know but really you know looking at this
again it's just it's you know I don't
think it stifles creativity because like
it exists in music and on films and
books to a large extent and we're still
seeing new music and new books being
written every day you know I don't think
it stifles creativity I think it
encourages people to be more unique
because you know you can't just rip off
someone else's idea right that you know
it's about encouraging people to come up
with unique stuff rather than just
ripping people off
I guess when it's done right yeah
exactly yeah this is the thing it has to
be done right yeah it's gonna take time
but it has to be done right it would
probably have to be like a very very
specific combination of like falling off
a plane with the red margon this is our
IP
but I mean that's how they do like
patents right well this ball is patent
him because it doesn't make noise when
you throw like yeah a shark tank yeah
game mode itself I don't think is
copyrightable you know that it's like
it's a last night can I ask you what
about your version of battle royale do
you think is uniquely yours I mean
honest I think like you know the plane
starting right now that's something I
came up with late I'm even like the
ever-decreasing blue circle right hey in
the movie The Hunger Games it's a
different zone in the battle royale the
book it's a square but I couldn't code
either of those so right right it's an
ever decreasing circle right so that was
my creation for this but that's not a
unique idea watch though if you're the
first guy who did that I mean that
counts for something but what are those
together are is is make as a big part of
why the game special yeah I mean I'm the
dilute system the way that the new
system works the randomness of it you
know that I don't think it's a big
factor but you know the way that we
planned the loot system internally I
think is a big factor why it's so
replayable you know and because if you
control all three of those aspects get
Alma it really depends oh no I wouldn't
want to control these are like
hypothetically you know even the loot
system came from Daisy so like that's
where that vote for me like the unique
things that I kept like the red zone you
know that didn't exist in any of the the
movies or books it's like the air raid
yeah yeah you know the blue circle and
the jumping out of a plane that's what I
think is three things I created from my
version about Royale on ARMA right and
yeah that's kind of what I consider it
like my ideas yeah you know not
necessarily unique ideas but they're
what I made into a game right but again
you know it's you know it's it's a it's
a long road for us you know we don't
want that as I said we don't want to
stifle creativity you wanna don't wanna
like you know shut down competitors you
know we we just want to find ways to
maybe protect people's ideas in the
future you know it's not you want to set
a legal precedent well yeah we want to
protect you know first it's always been
like even you know when we've heard this
all came to like prominence a few months
ago it wasn't about people copying us
it's about you know that it's about
setting up you know maybe IP protection
you know that you
big companies ripping off little
companies shouldn't really it doesn't
it's not really allowed to happen
another medium so why is it so okay in
gaming right it's like it's still the
Wild West so to speak in gaming kind of
especially with so many indie developers
coming up now and yeah so yeah let's see
okay that's fair enough for sure hmm uh
what what is it about your game that you
think was so successful clearly it was
like the perfect time the perfect game
perfect place what's going on there I
think it's like it's unique every time
it's like as we said earlier it's a
unique story every time you play the
game but I think it's it's the freedom
we give the players like there's no
right way to play the game you know that
if you want a high action game drop at
school yeah if you don't just open early
and get the [ __ ] away from everyone
right that there's that freedom to play
however you want you know if you want to
run a pistol round do it you know you
want to run with just snipers do it that
people love shooter games and this is
like a shooter game with all the
mechanics of a lot of the games that
people love but with a unique and unique
battlefield every time basically you
know so I think it's because it's that
easy and it is tough to learn you know
it's like I think what's the to win your
first ever battle royale or first the
first ever game of battlegrounds a think
it's 1 in 6,000 see right okay your
chances of winning is one at six does it
for the first time that's pretty
incredible dudes feet getting struck by
lightning is 1 in 3,000 okay right so
like it's really rare right so but you
know it's a good it takes time to learn
the game you know learn how the recoil
system works and learn to be better at
the game you know and and the further
you play the game or the more you get
the more you learned that the orangie
doesn't really matter because like you
see especially with the pro teams you
know they never die earlier on because
they know to get away from people right
there their map awareness is like they
have like spidey senses oh yeah
unbelieva they like know exactly where
how to run and nowhere I guess that's
what happens played for thousands of
hours oh this is like a lot of like
especially the pro teams they're either
you know X ARMA 3 B or players or h1
players and they've been playing a long
time you know some of the four years
like Marius who's like an ex ARMA 3 BR
player
he plays with the dust keyboard without
any of the keys right so it's just it's
just a block right and he played ARMA on
these controls like army is really tough
to play because it has a such a let's
have a competitive advantage that I can
never dream of yes yes they yeah
marius would kill you even if he wasn't
on your server wow that's a great guy
real life hasn't killed anyone yet
what's your opinion on doctor disrespect
and not just him specifically but seems
like a large reason for the game's
popularity is also how we were talking
earlier how watchable it is yeah a lot
of people PewDiePie mm-hmm
made a ton of videos of home playing
which was I mean it was already big at
the time when he started playing but
like he really him and people like
doctor disrespect a lot of other twitch
streamers really made it the mainstay of
of their oh yeah I mean gaming I saw it
like from when I first started this way
back in dayz dayz mod' I didn't watch
you - I didn't watch twitch I didn't
know about streaming like played games
occasionally you know and then I'd hear
people like oh captain sparkles is
playing your mod and I'm like who the
[ __ ] is captainsparklez and going thing
oh wait million subscribers right and
you know and hearing these like going
and seeing lyric you know when their
account like 15k or somebody that and
seeing these people that like you know
that I had no idea about but holy [ __ ]
there's a lot of people watching them
right so you know it's twitch has helped
this game grow for sure you know and you
know seeing these guys that they see me
as you said make it their mainstays like
it's it's amazing it's like you know see
people like PewDiePie or disrespect
playing the game is just it's great you
know I think I was looking on PewDiePie
shell he has he recorded a whole game
where he gets first place yeah and it's
like an hour plus long and has like 10
million views
that's incredible you know it's nuts you
know it's the level of exposure that
gets you is crazy you know right now I'm
just thankful people enjoy the game you
know yeah
I'm PewDiePie follows me now so yeah but
when you were designing the game you
never did you think about like hey that
was a great game to watch know why but I
heard what was it like Jeff Kaplan from
Blizzard he said in an interview that
like
beauty of battle royale is that or the
beauty belgrad's is the pacing is that
kind of up and down that's something
I've always wanted was that you know at
the start it shouldn't be exciting
exchange
yeah it should be kind of like you're
losing at the start then you go into a
bit of action maybe in the mid game then
it's quiet again and then a bit more
action so especially for streamers it
allows them to sit and chat right there
you know with their their chat basically
and it's not all action all the time and
I think that's what why it's been so
popular is that you know you have it's a
horror game dressed up as a shooter game
you know that it's you have that opened
down motion and that kind of nice flow
to the game doctor district had
threatened to kick you in the chest
walked on Twitter and you had taken the
threat seriously
no I didn't know that so I didn't take
the bread service tea right it's like I
made a point about like threatening
quads because honestly like I mean I'm a
big believer it's like you know this
world is shitty enough you know why be
nasty shoot oh and I know what's his
character but this is the Internet and
there's probably going to be a few
people right see this we were having a
good we were having a good bit of banter
he says in my house you follow the rules
are you gtfo and then he responded if I
could do the splits I'd read how Cassie
bran house kick you in the neck but
since I can't I'll front kick you in the
chest instead oh yeah so like this but
you got something you wrote like a long
Twitter oh yeah no no I
there was a nice nice story behind it
when I was in college I kicked through a
glass window by a really drunk and he
was hassling my other Finnish flatmates
and like he like pushed one in the back
in the stairs and I came home was like
what the [ __ ] and he just kicks me into
the chest and I fell backwards head
through the bass window falling ground
get up he's looking for shot to punch
him into the nose break his nose and and
I just got bad but you know but no but I
mean I really like the reason I address
that was that like I have a brother back
home that like suffers from PTSD and
Servite this from I he was in a car
accident
Oh ten years ago and killed some young
lad oh yeah no no proper PTSD right and
like wakes up screaming at night so you
know I know that this kind of stuff can
be triggering to people and what
concerned me most about that was like
this and the docs fans are great but
there's probably that 1% that
don't really see it a satire you know
and I don't want to be looking over my
shoulder conventions you know there's
someone that will come up and kick me to
the chest just to make the dog proud you
know that kind of like he inspires that
kind of like zealotry almost that like
people love love the doc right so for me
which is making a stance that listen
violence is not okay
like I'm just with the record please
don't kick me in the chest through a
glass window
yeah listen if you can try I may break
your nose okay but no I mean it's
honestly it's like for me it's just
making a point that like you know the
world is shitty enough as it is let's
not go around like hating each other you
know it's like you know I love the docs
character but like to be honest like
come on like life is [ __ ] like let's try
to lift people up instead of put people
down right what do you think about the
well he he obviously has been a fair bit
of controversy you saw that no what was
your did that come as a surprise to you
what did you think about that I didn't
think anything like no it's a personal
matter between his family like I mean
yeah I completely agree it's so personal
that I don't know I mean yeah I'm being
a hundred percent yeah it was just such
an interesting thing I I don't want to
say anything about it he was a guest our
show yeah I think I hung out with him as
his wife sweet lovely like and his wife
is lovely so you know that's their thing
I hope they sorta die you know I really
do yeah very professionally stated no I
can't think it personal [ __ ] my like you
know this is like drama internet bad
this is real life and this is serious so
you know it's like let's leave them the
[ __ ] alone
yeah yeah I felt bad for everyone
involved there hmm there is no
definitely no no winners there no well
how about that hmm
I'm suddenly the tone of the show yeah
how about that I wanted to ask I wanted
to ask you more about hackers sure do
you notice them coming from like a
certain country is there a certain kind
of person what's going on with the
hacker like is there only onions that
you see there's I mean there's a large
percentage of hackers that are cheaters
that come out of
of China and it's it's mainly because
it's very accepted there to cheat in
games oh yeah I mean it's it's quite is
that a commentary on Chinese culture as
a whole I have a friend who lived and he
was saying in China because there's so
many people mm-hmm unlike in America or
Western society it's very like I get
what's mine and [ __ ] everyone else
mm-hmm there's they don't have like a
collective yeah no yeah I'm just
obviously a broad stroke ela saying you
should have said that well interesting
conversation I stay for the celebration
so why do you think you said yourself no
listen it's acceptable in China nobody
is seen to be okay to get a leg up in
games by using sheets right it's it's
it's it's more commonplace there you
know then and say in the West but as
well it's because there's so many child
like our numbers on Steam are mainly
because of China like our peak is
because it's because like so could you
guess what percentage are Chinese just a
ballpark oh no you can see it on on
these days by so you can see it it's
like 60 odd percent oh oh no it's it's a
massive percentage like I mean I didn't
realize how big China was so like dota
and csgo they run their own builds in
China right they have perfect world
distributing so you don't get to see
that the Chinese CC which is probably
like a million or not are more of people
playing in China with our game you get
to see the Chinese market so you get to
see that you know million or you know
two million CC you because of China like
China is a huge market like you look at
the alien oh wait look at $0.10 we chat
up a billion people use it but about a
billion in like it's insane numbers so
yeah it was it was very eye-opening to
me when I saw numbers from China that
would explain why them
most of the hackers are also from China
oh like 60% what if it's a per capita
thing that's the question um I mean that
we're a lot of the cheats we see coming
out new cheats are
are 99% are coming out of China you know
that there they've got some very skilled
cheaters there hello ladies like matrix
level programmers they're just spending
their time ruining games
oh it's massive like it's a massive
money-making industry like cheating in
general like some of the private cheats
for some of like the big games you're
paying maybe a thousand dollars a month
by selling so the guy who writes it
sounds it for $1,000 a month you know
and it's a prescriptive subscription
Maurya Wow but that's like high level
[ __ ] like oh yeah so say there's this
boutique hacker he's charging $1,000 a
month for his clients is are you ever
gonna catch something bad oh he did
catch one we caught one that was being
like someone had paid 10 grand or
something for for a chief and we caught
the private sheet and we banned them you
know and it was just like Guardian oh ya
know I mean it's like listen if you
wanna pay we're gonna catch it you know
it just takes time to analyze everything
you know so luckily like I would say
99.9% of the public cheats out there we
detect we you're not getting if you want
to cheat you still have to go private
right you have to go there route of
private cheats and and they're expensive
you know so surprise when I learned
about these hacking communities they
charge a lot of money oh yeah and and
monthly that's a lot of them are $30 a
month oh yeah oh no it's it's in massive
and it's amazing dollar oh yeah it's
like it's the amount I can I don't
understand it like I you know I do
understand because people want to be the
best I was here when I was off like 13 I
used cheats in CSKA or seus and guys
please look I'm still the same person
anything you have always known no when I
was 13 and likes 1.6 I installed a hat
school mostly I was just curious sure
what it's like I want to know what these
[ __ ] guys are saying and it is
unbelievable I remember some of the
heck's I used back in 1.6 there's like a
laser that shoots from the tip of your
gun okay so you can see exactly there's
radio points like like you've got one
axis going up and down and oh yeah right
like infinity x-ray comes back so you
can see at any point where they're
looking which direction they're facing
were they're coming there's what you can
see through walls
there's headshot scripts there's
everything you can imagine and it's fun
it's like thrilling for like a couple of
days oh yeah and then you're like well
this is [ __ ] pointless yeah you don't
have anything exact there's no skill
involved it's just running around and
knowing who everyone's coming from it's
okay I'm number one but you're not
really yeah I guess I guess it's just a
cycle new people wanted to pay up for it
yeah but it probably is but I mean you
get these people that just and it's like
the 10 they add like the 10% and they're
very hard to catch because they're not
being obvious about their cheating you
know they're only turning it on maybe in
the final ten or something I thought
that you know that it's right it's tough
but we we do catch them you know if
there's there's ways and then means to
analyze them so you know it's it just
takes time but you know we yeah it's an
ongoing battle you see a world where
hackers is there know what our hackers
we wouldnt have some of the biggest
companies in the world because they were
born from hackers they were born for
people going how does this work let's
take this apart to see how it works and
that's why I think hackers like I don't
disrespect them because I think they're
incredibly smart they really are and you
know when put to good use
like they can really create some
wonderful town bus dude spend your time
on something more productive please you
guys are looking for good help right I
mean it's let's go
yeah but then can you trust them no no
cuz I mean like I know like the
communities and like for the commute for
you to be respected among a community
you have to bring and show work right
that's the only way they let you in if
they don't if you don't have work to
show or hacks you've done you're not
getting in there so you know for me
employing a hacker is always very risky
because they may be doing it just to be
in the thing and then they'll be able to
leak stuff especially if they're in
another country it's very hard to pursue
legal action as well so we have no no
please don't please don't I respect you
guys but like sorry no job here what's
your favorite game of all time oh god I
loved Delta Force Black Hawk Down which
one dr. Forrest Black Hawk Down I never
know it was was that for it was PC and I
was on next box as well I think our
PlayStation and it was just a military
sim but it had modding it had that
custom maps and stuff like that and it
was the first one that had
like weapon ballistics so like you had
to aim above him the bullet would drop
all that kind of the I'll oh I played
that that was your inspiration I think
or like those kind of games I see in you
yeah no looking back I've really
inspired me because that in America's
Army they're the kind of games i like i
like realistic shooters you know and you
were born on or raised i don't be born
on a military base right I was born in
up the north of Ireland and Ballyshannon
but I grew up on a military base do you
think that info get your tastes and all
this Oh 100% I'd used to play war with
my friends and run obstacle courses and
you know the range there are strange
ring were practicing like a house behind
us they call like a bomb house and they
go and do tactics and stuff and then
they come out and show us their weapons
so I was loved guns I was loved that
sort of realism and shooter games like
that America's Army and Black Hawk Down
were that yeah they really kind of drew
me in and to this day i like military
shooters that's what I like playing I
think I've never played Pokemon I've
never played like Zelda never really
yeah just no interest no interest you
know the great game is but I like my
military shooters I like that kind of
yeah real is your carboy you like God no
God people do love called it's too fast
not too small I like a bit of
battlefield just because the maps a bit
bigger and bright it's a like especially
battlefield one I I play a lot of
because it's quick and easy but for the
most part here I'm military shooters I
would say that you created the dream
that I always or the game that I always
dreamed of playing when I was a kid
learning like I would be like what happy
awesome if you could have a hundred
people like back in the 90s when oh yeah
you know multiplayer games was like one
verse one Starcraft 2 or something would
it be amazing if you have a hundred
people in a huge map and do something
like that and I you've made it you've
made my dream game and a lot of people's
clearly yeah I mean then the story of
how you overcame with pretty much no
resources from from modding to this is
inspirational very cool man thank you
for coming and sharing your story with
us thanks for having me let's be yeah
there's one last thing sure that
everyone insists that I ask you I guess
it's okay
if you can't answer it so don't worry
about it do you have any ghost stories
or paranormal experiences UFO sightings
what do you think about all that
ghosts yep okay great all right thanks
for God
UFOs for sure have you seen UFOs Wow do
you believe that they visit the earth mm
maybe not sure like a flap on that room
you know it's like look I believe in
UFOs
I believe in like in life and other
plants but I don't know if they visited
here I'm not I like I mean I don't know
I'd like to think they have I'm with you
I'm with very big not like the classic
like seeing something in the sky yeah
you know there's a story that just came
out that the FBI or the Homeland
Security was fun did you hear this
hmm was funding up until just a couple
years ago that actual UFO research
branch of the government
oh yeah and it just came out they just
made a public and a lot of people are
freaking out about it but I don't I'd
love to think that we've been contacted
and I love it right I mean it's like I
want to meet alter its the phrase of
like you know were too old to explore
the earth and too young to explore stars
you know this and that kills me because
like I want to know enough for dankmemes
as they say well thanks for coming out
there's a lot of it was a joy as a
pleasure it was a blast
everybody thank you so much for watching
leave your questions for Tommy Wiseau on
the subreddit and way probably oh yeah
let me see your shirt everyone was
saying right they have big big plans for
this winner winner chicken dinner
very exclusive stuff so stay tuned we
get the big plans here see you guys next
Friday it's the last episode of season
one of the agent podcast but we'll talk
about more about that next week so
thanks for watching guys have a great
weekend thanks for spending time with us
hila thank you yeah big fans who isn't
dance a big flame Austin Austin says hi
by the way oh okay he wants to play
Babji with you oh really
yeah okay I'd be formed have you won by
the way before Oh only when I've had to
nur our gameplay dev on the team he's
you've never do play solo no never
no yeah plus like if I play one game in
the office I won't play 10 right so like
playing what squads it's kind of good
because then ok ok yeah we're done so
you've only won a couple of times
because you were carried exactly very
interesting although when I first played
ARMA 3 with the team internally I won a
thought but that's because it's ARMA 3
yeah it's yeah but no never in poky okay
good to know
even the creator and I am a loser to be
wearing that shirt
no alright thank you guys for watching
we'll see you next time
na
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]